Kilda my name is just under our dune and  I wanted to share just a very quick  message as you're all very enjoying the  [ __ ] youth Awards this evening I hope you  all having a wonderful time I just want  to just send a little message because  there's some think about your awards  that really struck me firstly that it's  by youth for youth I think that's  absolutely fantastic  but the thing that really stood out for  me is the nature of the awards that  you're giving out tonight they say to me  that what young people value and their  peers and those around them things like  compassion things like being a good  sport and showing some kindness to  people around you they're all qualities  that I really admire that I do think  should be rewarded and acknowledged so  I'm so pleased that you're doing that at  your Awards tonight have a fantastic  evening please my warmest  congratulations to you all  I think Gore is very lucky to have you